Transcriber: Maram Turkya
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
شكرًا لكم، في البداية أقول صباح الخير.
أنا مبسوط كثيرًا كوني معكم
في هذا الحدث الرائع كثيرًا،
والذي تنظمه مدارس اليوبيل،
وأنا مبسوط كثيرًا
للتعرّف عليكم ولتعرفكم عليّ،
لم أتعود أن أتحدث كثيرًا
لأنني أستخدم لغة هي لغة الموسيقى.
ولغة الموسيقى؛
هناك عبارة كنتُ دائمًا أحبها تقول،
تموت الحروف حين تُقال.
يمكن أن يكون هناك أناس تحب الحكي
أو تعرف أن تحكي،
وفي أناس لا تقدر التعبير عن نفسها بالكلام،
وفي أناس تقدر أن تعبر عن نفسها بالفنون.
والفنون هي الجسر الموصّل
بين الحضارات، هي لغة الشعوب.
دائمًا عندما نتعرف على أشخاص
ليسوا من حضارتنا وثقافتنا ولغتنا،
قد نكون في حيرة وفي قلق كيف نحكي معهم.
كانت الموسيقى الجزء الأكبر في حياتي لأعرف
كيفية التواصل مع كل الحضارات في كل العالم،
حيث سافرت إليها وتعرفت عليها،
وشاركتها في الموسيقى.
وقفت كثيرًا على مسارح،
وعزفت مع أناس لا أعرف لغتهم.
قد أعرف الحكي بلغتي الأم،
وهي اللغة العربية،
واللغة الإنجليزية التي
تعلّمتها في المدارس.
لكن لا أعرف اللغة الفرنسية ولا الروسية،
ولا اليابانية، واللغة الهندية لا أعرفها.
لكن عند كل بلد ذكرتها لكم
حضارة كبيرة كثيرًا.
الحضارة هي جذور، الحضارة مثلما ترون،
عندما نلبس هذا الثوب،
أو نمسك هذه الآلة التي هي آلة الناي،
أو نأكل الأكلات الشعبية
التي نحبها، هذه هي حضارتنا.
اللغة التي نستخدمها مع بعض،
ونتواصل بها مع بعض، هذه هي الحضارة.
هذه هي الجذور التي تربينا عليها وتعلمناها،
ودائمًا نحبُ نقلها من جيل إلى جيل.
أنا اليوم مبسوط لأنكم مهتمين
في نقل هذه الحضارة،
يوجد بين أياديكم وسائل حلوة كثيرًا.
ربما كانت البدايات في وقتنا
فيما يخص التقنية،
وأنتم الآن مبدعون في التقنية.
كما قالت زميلتنا دارين
أننا استخدمنا وقت الكورونا ...
صار كل واحد فينا يفكر فيما سيعمله،
ويتساءل ما يمكن عمله،
استغليتُ هذه الفترة وقلت،
يجب أن أبدع في آلتي وأوصلها إلى كل العالم،
لأن كل الناس في تلك اللحظة
كانت مضطرة للبقاء في بيوتها.
وبالنسبة لي شعرت بالانبساط صراحة،
وقلت هذه فرصتي للشهرة.
صحيح كنت معروفًا في الوسط: الأردن، لبنان،
تونس، الجزائر؛ يعني في البلاد العربية.
ولكن قلت أن هذه هي فرصتي
لأن كل الناس كانت مضطرة للبقاء في منازلها.
يتعين أن أعمل شيئًا لآلة الناي ،
هذه الآلة العربية،
وجذورها تمتد من سبعة آلاف سنة،
لم يتغير شكلها شكلها أبدًا مثلما ترونها
فهي مصنوعة من القصب.
يكمن أصل تاريخها بالجذور، لم يصنع الإنسان
هذه الآلة ولم يتدخل في صناعتها.
قد وُجدت في الطبيعة مثلما هي في الأرض.
الذي سيزور منكم المناطق
قرب وادي شعيب والأغوار،
سيجد قصبًا كثيرًا قد نما
عند ضفاف الأنهار وعند المياه.
هذه الآلة وُجدت في الطبيعة مثلما هي.
ما عمله الإنسان أنه حضر وقطعها،
وجففها من المياة الموجودة في داخلها،
وعمل مجموعة من الثقوب ليقدر أن يُخرج
من روحه هذا الشجن الذي سمعتموه.
قد يقول بعض الناس أن هذه الآلة حزينة،
ممكن، لأن لدى الإنسان بطبعه مشاعر كثيرة:
يحزن ويفرح، لكن الشجن
هو ما بين الحزن وما بين الفرح.
كلنا يفرح وكلنا يحزن.
وعندما  أعبر بالموسيقى، فأنا أنفخ من الروح
لأحيي هذه الآلة مجددًا.
هذه الآلة انتقلت عبر الحضارات.
وأثبتوا أن مصدر هذه الآلة
هو حضارتنا العربية،
من الشرق، من الجزيرة العربية،
وانتقلت إلى أوروبا
وتطورت هذه الآلة
التي أصبح اسمها فلوت/flute.
وهناك آلات نفخ كثيرة متعددة،
يطلق عليها في الهند بان سوري،
ويسمونها flute/ فلوت في أوروبا،
لها أسماء متعددة كثيرة، لكن هذه هي الأصل.
تتمحور فكرة هذه الآلة أنه عندما أنفخ
من النَفس الذي بداخلي،
وهي أكثر آلة نفخية تعبر عن الروح،
هي تعبر عن مشاعري حيث أقدر أن أنقل لكم
هذه المشاعر من خلال ما تسمعونه.
الموسيقى، كما قال كونفوشيوس،
وهو فيلسوف صيني،
قال: “إذا أردت أن تعرف مستوى شعب،
فاستمع إلى موسيقاه“.
الرسالة التي أحب أن أوجها إليكم جميعًا،
يستمع جميعنا إلى الموسيقى،
لا يوجد إنسان الآن أو يسمعنا
إلا ويسمع موسيقى على اختلاف أنواعها.
هذا شيء جميل،  لأن الموسيقى
هي التي كوّنت الكون على أساسها.
الموسيقى لحن وإيقاع:
أقرب نموذج أقدر أن أقوله لكم
عن الإيقاع المنتظم هو ضربات القلب عنا.
الإنسان الذي ضربات قلبه منتظمة،
يبقى يعملُ حيث هو في إيقاع منتظم بحياته.
لا سمح الله، لو زادت أو قلت
يصبح هناك اختلال.
حتى حركة الكواكب هي إيقاع منتظم،
يعني عندما خلق ربنا الكون،
خلقه في إيقاع منتظم.
أما اللحن، العنصر الثاني،
فهو النغمات التي ننسجم معها ونسمعها؛
من أصوات الطبيعة إلى أصوات
الآلات الموسيقية ومن أصواتنا.
نحن أصواتنا موسيقى، لذلك،
أحب دائمًا أن أوجه رسالة إلى الجميع،
لنعرف ما الذي نسمعه،
الاستماع أو التذوق الموسيقي هو شيء مهم،
بمعنى كيف نسمع الموسيقى.
كما قلت لكم أنكم جميعًا تستمعون للموسيقى،
ومن المؤكد أن أذواقكم ترتقي في سماعها.
ولكن، مع التغيرات
التي تحدث قليلًا في الحياة،
أحيانًا يحدث التلوث السمعي
مثلما يحدث تلوث البيئة،
مثل: مصادر تلوث السيارات  والمصانع،
هناك يحدث التلوث السمعي.
من الضروري أن نكون حريصين
من أجل أن ترتاح نفسياتنا،
ولنبدع في حياتنا بكل التخصصات:
كالطبيب والمهندس والمحامي.
نحتاج جميعًا أن نسمع موسيقى
لكي نقدر أن نبدع،
لأنه عندما تدخل الموسيقى مخيلاتنا،
تجعلنا نبدع بالأفكار التي نفكر بها.
أجمل شيء في الموسيقى التي أحبها،
قد قدمتُ لكم قبل دقائق،
مشا أو ميدلي من ثلاث أنواع من الموسيقى.
بدأت في the Godfather أي العرّاب،
وهي موسيقى عالمية،
ربما سمعتم عنها في المؤلفات الغربية،
أو بالفيلم المشهور the Godfather.
ومن ثم عزفتُ أنا لحبيبي
وحبيبي لي للسيدة فيروز،
وبعدها عزفتُ  Love Story أي قصة حب.
حاولت عمل رحلة ما بين الشرق والغرب.
ما صنع بسحره أنها هي مجموعة
من السلالم الموسيقية المستخدمة،
وكيف أقدر التنقل ما بين ثلاثة أمزجة
أو ثلاثة أذواق مختلفة مع بعض.
ولكن صحيح أن هذا شيء حلو
ويصل إلى العالم كله،
لكن ما يجعلني مبسوطًا ومنفعلًا
وسعيدًا وعندي طاقة،
دائمًا الموسيقى تعطينا طاقة،
الموسيقى الشعبية.
هويتنا والموسيقى الشعبية،
هذا معنى كبير جدًا،
الموسيقى الشعبية حيث عندما أذهب على عُرس
يجري تكافل اجتماعي مثل الدبكة،
هذه الدبكة نفسها هي  تكافل الاجتماعي.
نحن نتعاون مع بعض للحظة حلوة.
أو كان هناك أغاني يستخدمها
آباؤنا وأجدادنا التي هي مثل:
عندما كانوا يذهبون لحصاد القمح،
كان هناك أغاني لحصاد القمح.
أو عندما كان شخص ما يهاجر من بلد إلى بلد،
كانوا يغنون أغاني يعبرون فيها
عن حنينهم لأوطانهم ولبلادهم.
من المؤكد قد سمعتم
كل هذه الأغاني بأشكال مختلفة.
ولكن هذا الشيء أحب كثيرًا أن تسعموه
بالأسلوب الذي يتناسب مع العصر.
لأنني إذا أردت القول
هيا بنا نرجع للأغاني القديمة.
حسنًا، لم نُخلق مع الجيل القديم،
نحن خُلقنا اليوم.
هيا بنا نسمع الأغاني القديمة والموسيقى
العربية الكلاسيكية والموسيقى التراثية.
ونهتم في تعلّم العزف على آلاتنا للعربية،
وإن أردنا عدم تعلّم العزف عليها،
حيث كل واحد فينا يختلف عن الآخر.
فهناك مَن يحب الموسيقى ومن يحب الرياضة،
ومَن يحب السباحة ومن يحب الفنون بشكل عام،
وهناك مَن يحب الطبخ، الطبخ طيب صراحة،
وهو أهم شيء في الموضوع.
فدائمًا أقول اهتموا بشيء
تحبونه وأبدعوا فيه.
ودعوني أعيش معكم لحظة الطاقة،
لأننا جميعًا نحتاج إليها.
هيا بنا.
(تصفيق)